you
all right we are at the 10-minute Aria
ten seconds to go here less than ten
five seconds to go and this one the
Meijer tournament this is 45 second
chess time burning skills very important
pre moves early on very important very
very important let's see I already
broken down here it's already broken
down a little bit my night is going to
dance let's just throw them right in
here even as a sack even as a sec don't
make me over here hmm okay
I should have prevented that my dark
squares are hurting me they're
definitely hurting me I want to get rid
of their night not easy to do
Oh why'd I do that
okay I got to take there and make sure I
get rid of this pun as soon as possible
as soon as possible
mm-hmm got to get over here my king is
ready to be a cot in the center for her
in the corner for forever okay my night
is going to try and hunt down that pond
actually okay let's take and I guess no
not so fast not so fast
oh boy need some I need some air I need
some air how's the clock um
how are we doing how we doing hmm
I need a tricky night I'm gonna I'm
going to cash out okay I got to do time
burners so what I was talking about time
burners I could have just taken that
why'd I do that
are we doing I'm in check I'm down a
time oh ah that pond went wild he took
my night I thought I was going to get a
skewer there a checking and get they're
clean they took my night promoted got a
queen and said uh-huh urine check not so
fast
all right shake it off man shake it off
oh my goodness
there he goes again quoting lyrics
quoting lyrics quoting lyrics okay get
rid of that guy pre move pre move take
that g7 phone why don't you he's free
isn't he just go here 34 seconds get out
of here night you're no good to me
no good let's not weaken let's not
weaken the king position with your EFT
on my queen wants to play here it's a
good square take here
even if be for because their Queens are
protected got to go faster okay oh okay
here no matter what here no matter what
yeah this might be a first in the last
it might be a first in the last push g4
I'm okay here no back rank
mates doctor chairman okay okay get a
win under your belt and go from there
that's the plan twenty-six minutes
remain
whoo okay okay okay uh uh yeah don't
expect to learn too much from this this
is a crazy time control let's see
tempo take let's take with the night
actually Wow
okay gonna have an ending just go fast a
lot of pre moves do a little night dance
here there frame ovary capture throw
your age fun
keep throwing him kick a night secure
your king position defend g4 kick the
night again crash up in the queenside
um yeah no no I didn't want to do that I
didn't want to do that I promise oh man
I didn't want to do that you're just
gonna have to believe me
oh I can't even move my I need to keep
one piece around ah man I didn't want to
do that I got a night I got a do no I
have to hang on to my rook for sure
create tension and don't release it okay
15 seconds they have they're going to
take the pump power of suggestion did
not work duck duck the exchanges man be
a duck er I don't know what that means
man don't question don't question it
checks keep the rook throw check time
burning be a time burning magician I
don't know what I'm doing oh boy and
over here and then there
good take care with check
some checks more checks time burning hmm
neither one of us wants to capture peace
there down a time oh my goodness
this is ridiculous this is a ridiculous
format I've done I went to draw oh my
goodness it's ridiculous its
ridiculousness at 45 seconds and we're
just prepping for maybe a first and last
situation playing a 30 second tournament
yep if you think this is ridiculous
it gets even more ridiculous but you got
to try it at least once while recording
right at least once once and done throw
your knight on a four Knights on the rim
are not always grim not always alright
let's take them out and let this guy be
an animal the dark square bishop wants
to be an animal now crack open the
center wow I was down way too much
material I don't know opposite the Queen
probably good idea
um okay get out there office color
Bishop's let's play over here okay let's
crack at their dark squares Bishop on d4
beastly a be sleepy so we're staring at
mate now keep that pin let's check keep
the pin keep the pin here whoa that's a
freebie might resign no not going
anywhere okay here throw your pawn keep
pushing not really doing very well to
convert this so much more efficient way
take a look take a row
Cabo okay one and then two got it back
to tournament hmm man my heart is racing
21 21 minutes 35 seconds 16 16 13 8 is
where I stand
ah that guy that beat me in the first
where is he I don't see him on the top
anywhere okay maybe I should start
berserk huh there you go this is too
much time right 45 seconds too much time
mm-hmm let's take here recapture like
that towards the center break in the
center here close to matter what
recapture with check don't block with
the pawn made on g2 late on g2 made on
g2 ok let's take there it's an illegal
move you can't do that who's gotten that
before
uh-hum pass on watch out for on pass on
if you do that against a player who is
just learning the game you will get
accused of cheating it's just how it is
everyone has been accused of cheating
who knows the rules okay it's ready to
check no matter what throw rook here
don't okay to have pawns they can move
that's me back determine at point three
twenty twenty twenty twelve twelve
twelve is where I stand 20 minutes
remain in the game my tournament in the
game in the tournament okay couple
flawless guys up here oh my goodness all
right there they're going to play Bishop
d7 pre-move I had a fork at the end no
trade Forks doesn't matter it doesn't
mater get it f7 defend runaway oc5 sit
what's that about
I like dropping your knight is that what
you like doing ce-5 how about your
castle won't be bad I should it's a good
idea to castle at some point hmm
gotta go back home if d3 oh boy that's a
scary move haha that's a scary move mmm
okay I've been doing very good with
giving material back actually up on the
clock surprisingly check here oh they
did that they did that oh boy I'll take
that pond the fish is going to give a
check and get mated it made it mm-hmm oh
boy God do this they got a discovery Oh
discovered double check oh that's not
even said right discover it's just
double check mate aah
it's a painful way to lose double check
me you never want to go down with double
check mate ah man it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you win material
against that guy just giving you a heads
up just giving you a heads up okay come
on get all your pieces working all of
them working I didn't want to do that I
didn't know I want to do that let's try
this oh boy oh boy
let's take care there bishop I'm on
there not
take here
they're heavy peace ending alone let's
take their while they are flying they're
really cooking I'll take care and be
careful about my dark squares hopefully
c3h6 let's kick him out here let's give
a check then here look to get the Queen
stay active actually there we go get the
King on a light Square and move you
should be able to pre move the rest of
this game unless you do that push King
position Queen on a light square they
resigned back determine Wow just a giant
rat race giant rat race 28 28 22 2014 14
is where I stand not quite at the
halfway point okay
oooh speed bump for this guy Ferrari is
back again
okay green trade Queen trade don't kill
me on h2 I'm gonna play h5 ya got defend
there Oh Queen takes there okay alright
I could uh I could weather this storm
right I could weather this storm
I should take take their night out let's
drop all the way back get rid of their
Knight hit the rook alright let's just
do this to get made it on h1 oh it's
close to happening man how are they so
successful breaking down my position
let's come here double and then smash a
g6 ok this is actually working because I
get their Bishop they're going to fly
their King is going to run like wild yep
how did I know how did I know you're
going to start flying really how did I
know that here come some checks
give me that rook get rid of your rook
go King go King back up over here make
sure they're silly pawn doesn't move no
sneak attacks allowed here make sure you
get they'll have any mating material no
stalemates
hmm why is it isn't it mate
there was a little lag there or
something back to tournament oh my
goodness less than 15 minutes remain how
is the thirty second tournament going to
be don't ask me thirty twenty eight
twenty two twenty I'm at 16 in why isn't
third game there it is I don't know why
I'm starting with b3 just so I could
play Bishop b2 without any fear
Oh - look at this guy wild and crazy
King variation wild in crazy King let's
point pieces right at them d6 is
collapsing you have to devote a knight
to its defense it's getting blasted open
this is the new target uh seems
appealing tricky night on e6 ah let's go
here uh just feels too good not to do
push um hmm not playing this well got to
watch out for h2 the Queen's gonna kill
me
I need another open file I can also take
a free night don't be afraid to do that
defends h2 beautiful beautiful and watch
out for g2 fortunately have this skewer
Oh No they had h2 again let's take a
look
run over here they're in a pen just take
them here just so you can move fast
everything's coordinated stay
coordinated
throw in a check on back here over here
safe
push your pawn take run back check
Wow I learned a lot from this game I'm
gonna try taking running back and stuff
it's gonna work out beautiful I'm gonna
win a lot of games with that tactic run
pond run you are dangerous
you are dangerous they resigned back to
tournament ha ha ha oh man
3331 speechless speechless sort of
Sicilian it's a Chilean don't forget
about h2 you could you could go for
quick kills pac-man pulling here they're
going to push
let's get castle before the rook hurts
me anyone kill their dark square bishop
develop being kettle back your Bishop up
for may 10 h2 name of the game name of
the game now scare their night away
that's the next that's the next phase
improve your Bishop flight square take
with the knight throw them into f4 let's
just offset their night
let's take get rid of that pawn here
lining it up it's not mate but lots of
that's a freebie then I resign
hmm ok let's keep him and just push hang
on hang on let's keep it really simple
they resigned back determine oh my
goodness thirty eight thirty three
twenty six twenty six twenty four less
than 12 minutes remain Wow okay
I feel like I have to go faster and four
sharper stuff okay I've done this before
let's try it again
okay my knight on d4 hmm and the knight
back on here
okay their night is just way too good to
get rid of him
defend f7 could have also returned here
let's do this I don't know if it's best
to recapture like that with the bishop
in over the Queen's off mm knight on f6
not quite
Queen here seems very active my bishop I
need to reroute Queen trade yeah damage
structure I need to grant a home for my
night i bishop on e6 we'll have a good
home and yeah let's get to the seventh I
have a 10 second lead down objectively
alright throw your pone
throw in another check hit the bishop
improve the King position King right
here take with the pawn Kings there to
support activity a big-time lead oh no
no no not there that was not a good pre
move okay got this and now we're looking
for me got it back to tournament whoo 43
third my hand give me time to read the
numbers the numbers the score oh this is
a souped up Evans gambit watch out
it's the souped up Evans gambit okay I
like my bishop too much you give them up
and I win Reserve d3 it's the Evans
gambit the Juke variation of the Evans
gambit coming out wild with b4 and then
all of a sudden d3 I put on the brakes
whoa Inbetweeners and stuff
is that what's going on let's just take
material okay Knight here and then into
f4 drop your eforp on first
here here get my knight on g4 f5f for
finally this is my first real thought of
the game play f4 get a pawn break in and
drop a piece though get the Queen take
the knight then your Bishop on h6 hit
the rook hit the queen
don't fall for mate on g2 okay that's me
coming up dr. tournament 48:37 3632 mmm
yeah first is a long way off Wow stay
away from that preserve but what's
matter deal is your mouse really just
hover over the preserve button Wow yes
you really need to get your head checked
like right away withdraw the tournament
and just go get your head checked you
really need to do that okay we have to
defend dark squares I want to get rid of
their knight or queen no okay I could
take like this I'm really I'm tied down
I don't like the feeling I don't like
the feeling of being tied down here
trouble my queen
yeah um am I gonna be alright I need to
bank at this night I need to he's very
important to me he's very important hmm
no I gotta go here yeah this is very
scary
I need 7th ranked defense I could get
forked and everything their queen is on
the same could I go here is this working
is this somehow working I think it is oh
but there is that move just throw in
that check though throwing that check
and sack some stuff from down a rook ok
ok let's let's get my king over ooh I
have a knight now a free night Forks
over here Oh
over here stop that guy right there step
up here there here and then there
no right there is where we want to be
back to tournament Wow
that was a scary scary position that
allowed their queen and night to be in
Queen on h6 night on g5 my knight on f6
yeah
how important is he very important you
lose him you cooked your dumb turkey oh
man is it's almost Thanksgiving right
six minutes to go okay
I'm shooting for a second Ferraris gone
wild as usual this guy he's out he is in
second why isn't he moving he just moved
Oh the wing gambit the wing gambit okay
uh-huh
no thanks Queens off okay I feel like I
could play faster if the Queens aren't
around you know what I mean all right
that's a pawn this is a good square
let's go here Oh what's the knight up to
let's get pushing with this guy first
let's go all the way back guys are past
push and let's just keep pushing a
knight on f5 is gonna be good
keep pushing I should get to the 7th oh
no I shouldn't get to the 7th man I
shouldn't get to the 7th I got a fork
though I had a fork with the bishop too
though didn't I maybe they're gonna fall
for it no a direct kill a direct kill ok
here get your cane in a good position
hang on your knight he's important he's
very important very very important
okay role-reversal man check here have
your knight defend the pond scoop him up
first
oooh they don't have any time I realize
that never see that one coming back
determine 60 man he needs to slow down
60 I'm at 40 39 whoa okay quick L Knight
f6 yes hang on back to tournament 6044
3937 yeah I only need to pull that out
four more times
hang on hang on
oh if I could only do that four more
times it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen
ah this is some troll account huh yeah
I've played him before I have played him
before uh-huh
sneaky miss okay that night cannot be
tolerated
he just can't be tolerated pre moves
need flight square open files free rook
back to tournament they resign sixty
forty eight thirty nine three minutes to
go oh man okay uh go for scholars mate
and hope for the best go for scholars
mate golfers mmm
Duncan you're clean don't hang your
queen now hang on don't hang your queen
gonna play b5 I saw coming b4 b4 b4 no
matter what let's kill him can I clean
over on H 5 mmm ok here get rid their
light square bishop
soon-to-be mate actually let's defend
here for one defensive move one
defensive move H - H - f - quick kill
game over I can't take their this here
and then here is mate back to tournament
60 45239 two minutes remain
it's free more wins maybe yeah it's not
going to happen against this guy can it
you can't go two for two attempting
scholars mates oh yeah that's what it's
coming down to stop be five have to play
chess now you have to play chess okay
let's open up the C file they have some
juicy pieces there yeah fear it they
fear it let's go here and then here
Saxon material open stuff up push I'm
gonna push soon I could take my bishop
and be on my queen the queen sac here
for Forks on c6 family for kin coming
difficult to avoid Oh a whole farm a
whole farm and I get to take a piece
with double check discovered check um
let's check here no matter what I guess
they resigned back to Turman Wow less
than a minute uh less than a minute
just put your minor piece in front of
your center pawns it's good it's good
chess it's very good chess to do that
whenever you have the option to do that
make sure you're doing it oh it's
terrible it's terrible is what I mean by
that I got the Queen and then a fork
maybe they resign and I oh there's a
piece here
they're pin the night yes here huh can I
just get this one more this one more
game in in here I got to keep this file
open less than 10 seconds kill the night
ah I wanted to do that don't get back
cremated mate next free move ah turning
over I got to win this one now
ah man cut the King off um how's the
clock clocks fine turn it's over
swing over here go there let's just take
take that guy yeah this was this was one
of the more efficient ways to do it
there see if they could get both rook
pawns
alright this is this is the only way to
do it the way I'm doing it right here
no stalemates please no stalemates
no stalemates finally back to tournament
man I snuck in some pretty quick wins
towards the end but far from top dog
here
alright top was 7356 41 41 whoa I don't
know about these 45 second tournaments
craziness we're going to have to
investigate the thirty second ones
though just once at least we'll see
alright who took part in this one final
final list here 57 players page two
three four five six and that's it all
right to the
the seven of you who took part in the
Meyer tournament gee-gees
you